j'avais un marteau noël mon choix on
sort on marque on voit la marque on doit
le bond sera par contre toi dit les
crocos qui craqua où les bons jours
quelqu'un veut qu'il a bien le vrai le
week end dernier a eu lieu la 40e
cérémonie des césar et on a l'honneur
d'en recevoir le présentateur alors vous
avez pensé quoi de la soirée de vendredi
edouard baer mais vous savez moi je ne
crois pas qu'il y ait de bonnes
mauvaises
moi je devais résumer l'émission de
vendredi dernier avec vous je dirais que
ça a été un grand moment de télévision
rythmée et dynamique avec une
présentation d'une qualité
exceptionnelle et je parle bien sûr ici
ne touche pas mon post de vendredi
dernier présenté par enora et bien pas
des césar qui comme chaque année ont été
terriblement l'eau et n'ayons pas peur
des mots chiant à en crever alors vous
êtes sévère comme se trouve avec
vous-même et noir il ya quand même eu
deux beaux moments comme celui où vous
avez fait jouer un film à des gens dans
le public ça c'était sympa oui
effectivement j'étais au cash
ouais d'ailleurs j'aimerais reproduire
l'expérience gilles verdez pouvez vous
lire la réplique inscrits sur la fiche
qui vient de vous être remise à et à zut
alors j'ai encore le nez prix j'ai mal à
mon nez c'est embêtant d'avoir toujours
le nez qui coule
quel talent
il est allé on est vraiment c'était
bouleversant bravo gilles et bien sûr
vous avez tous reconnu le film un mouche
à bhl l'histoire sept personnes
handicapées qui ne peut même pas se
moucher seul voilà c'était il est d'une
grande finesse et d'une ex harel à
quartz et intellectuel que je vous
laisse mon cher mosher aussi rhinois
céciré lemercier d'elle merci à la colle
maintenant à des nommés aux césar c'est
françois damiens inverse qui avait fait
un carton sur des beats avec ses caméras
cachées françois patriat de ne pas avoir
été élu le meilleur comédien pour votre
rôle de sourd muet dans la famille
bélier oui un bon vivier belgique
non mais non françois on sait que vous
n'êtes peut être pas vraiment sourd et
que vous jouiez un rôle dans le film on
le sait de ce canal blanquet vous êtes
bien un bon d'être une cure
j'ai quand même te dire un truc en
langue des signes ghazi salaires merci
beaucoup c'était super bien
alors on reçoit maintenant un grand
comédien français c'est vincent cassel
vous avez trouvé ça comment la cérémonie
des césars rassemble donc j'ai trouvé ça
nul et c'est pourquoi c'était pourriels
ou narquois c'est pourquoi parce que je
n'étais pas parce que je trouve que dans
ton émission de ce soir face trouve
qu'elle est vraiment exceptionnel aussi
parce que je suis juste 10
les deux endroits les plus agréables où
j'ai été dans c'est quoi et bahia ton
émission ironique à bellucci
et il est cocasse où les cocasses où
aller chocolat est-ce que vous avez aimé
les césars vous lorànt deutsch on
attendra le cinéma c'est ma passion moi
ok bien sûr que j'ai regardé en plus des
césar ça se passe dans le magnifique
théâtre du châtelet châtelet éducation
des 14 a cette fois été inauguré en 1900
et tient son nom d'une prison sous
l'ancien régime
mais bon et vous en avez pensé quoi des
césars françois cluzet de choses à mon
peuple le savent les briser menu
cérémonie soporifique fait par des gens
de cinéma pour des gens du cinéma
ça fait 40 ans que la soi-disant grande
famille du cinéma ce regard de l'anus
à quel point il est magnifique qui a
laissé plus une cérémonie un ca rendez
vous chez le proctologue
là là je suis content la voilà ça oui là
y'a d'autres comédiens qui avait son
point de vue sur les césar c'est notre
ami jean claude van damme hockey bonjour
en voix et en dehors ça va être super
pouvoir bronzer
j'adore la tunisie à cause des sushis au
cannet césar mais césar c'est quoi ces
récompenses bon jouer la comédie 1 h
j'ai mal au secours j'ai peur oui oh oui
j'ai joué au hockey
sa copine tartas comme le tartare s'est
cru un tartare cru et un orage ô vous
l'entendez qui n'ont vous les voyez non
non plus ça veut dire qu'ils sont
silencieux et invisible c'est les pires
moments il fait toujours du bruit je
disais la drogue c'est mal
attila
la foule
allez c'est pas fini et pour terminer on
l'a l'honneur de recevoir le président
de la 40e cérémonie des césar il paraît
que vous avez été un petit peu frustré
dany boon à abbaretz jeter l'eau on
s'est bien fait chier un à temps c'était
la cérémonie des chézards en plus il ya
plein de blagues que je peux le refaire
par exemple quand julie gayet elle est
venue lui demander si elle préférait
avoir un césar dans sa main ou à
françois lançon qu on aille mais je
voulais parler le bal nouvelle comédie
romantique avec loana et pierre ménès et
pierre niney il a eu son césar pour le
rôle du saint laurent
je voulais le dire est pour une fois que
c'est un jeune ce média qui rentrent
dans la peau de saint-laurent et pour ça
le rock iran dans un comédien mark a
fait un discours nous le cherchons j'ai
le droit
partir comme ça pour le clip est ce que
vous pouvez nous dire tout ce qui va y
avoir après la pub on va voir aymeric de
cyclades story qui va venir nous voir on
parlera de tout ce qu'il ne fallait pas
non plus on dort à la comparaison du
jour les à bertrand chamerois qui va
venir lascaux pouvez nous le faire avec
la voix de gilles verdez s'il vous plaît
non mais attendez
c'est un scandale il y aura un bertrand
juste après la pub à